Hey, Tyler.
Okay.
Hey, how we doing?
Doing very good, Heather. How are you?
Pretty solid, can't complain.
Cool, you're going crazy, you're going crazy with FIFA.
Oh my god, it's been amazing.
So many controversies, and...
Yeah, it's been, it's been crazy. Even the US, like us getting that red card overturned was pretty crazy. And yeah, I didn't completely agree with that decision, but didn't matter anyway. We got our butts whooped.
Mhm.
Yeah, that's true. And I mean, yesterday's match, Egypt versus Argentina was...
Oh yeah.
I don't know. I have no words to explain. I mean, I'm a huge Messi fan, but what happened with Egypt was like, I don't know what to say.
Yeah, it was it was pretty crazy. Their coach was so mad too, which I would be too.
Yeah, and it's a difficult situation to be in when you were like 2-0 up and then within the last 15 minutes, everything just changed. And it changed so fast that we just don't know what to do.
Yeah.
Yep, that's how she goes sometimes.
Yeah, I mean, the world is divided about the controversy which is happening in a favoritism. I don't know what to say because end of the day, it's a sport, right? But the problem is when you, when you...
For sure.
When you have sports, then you add emotions to it. It actually becomes a different ballgame altogether. If you enjoy it as a sport, then it's fine. But when you, the moment you add emotions to it, it's going to go, you know.
No.
Yup.
South very quickly, it can escalate to any level because the motions are added and.
Yeah, it's tough, man. It's tough. India, we were supposed to, we were very close to get qualified this year, but it did not happen. So I'm being a neutral person. I feel for Egypt. That's all I can tell you. They, they, they.
For sure, who all made it from your, like, who all made it from your region?
Yeah, so India, I think we were, we were, I don't remember the group, but it was a very close match with Qatar and I think something even happened over there as well. There were a lot of controversies, so we just couldn't make it.
No.
That makes sense. Yeah, yeah, it sucks, man. It's going so fast too, like you wait four years for this and it just feels like it goes by in the blink of an eye, but it brings so many people together. So like having that controversy where it's like splitting people, it sucks to see.
Yeah.
Yeah, because nowadays...
With technology in the picture, you have so many, you know, cameras watching every second of what you're doing, right? And that's why it becomes even more complex. Then you have social media adding fuel to the fire. Everyone, everyone has their own opinion. Some are with you, some are neutral, some are against you.
Ohh yeah.
So there are so many complications around who to believe, who not to believe. It's such a difficult, it's an interesting world that we're living in. That's what I can tell you.
It really is. It really is. And like I think you said it best with the social media, man. I mean, that doesn't help anybody and people use it.
Ohh.
So, like, maliciously and to divide people in it, it sucks. I just don't, I don't know how we're ever gonna get out of that funk.
Yeah, that's one of the reasons I'm not on social media. I was back in 2000, maybe 7 or 8, I had my first Facebook account. But then I, but after like 2 years, I deleted my account because
Yeah.
To me, Facebook, social media was like waste of time, but I'm not, I wasn't getting anything, you know, valuable out of it. If you have a business, then great, you know, it makes sense, but you're spending way too much on your phone, you know, a lot of screen time, and if it's adding value, then it's fine. Otherwise...
To me, it's just a waste of time.
Yeah, I agree. There's so many, you see so many people go on like these cool trips and it's like, they post hundreds of pictures. It's like, did you even like enjoy the moment or were you just worried about like getting pictures for other people to see? It's crazy to me.
Ha ha.
Yeah, and...
And here's the fact, majority of social media is fake.
And sometimes, again, no offense to anyone, but that's what I think. You're just publicly making sure that your life is being watched by everyone. And then you talk about privacy.
Yup.
It's funny.
Yeah, exactly. It is funny. It's like they're trying to like validate themselves to other people. It's like I, I'm the same way. I'm on social media, but like I don't really do much on there. I follow a lot of sports on there and stuff. I never post or like anything like that. Like, so it's just purely like informational for me.
Yeah.
That's why I'm saying, you know, we are living in an interesting world where so many things are happening and we just don't know where to, who to believe, what should we do next? News, I don't believe news. I don't believe social media. It's like difficult, like what to do now.
Yep.
Yeah.
Same here. Same here. The news, the news all leans, they all get funded by somebody. And the news that they decide to highlight is tied to who is funding them. So it's very, it's very crooked. It really is. It's sad to think about.
Good.
Yeah.
****.
Yeah, I mean, at the moment, it is what it is, right? You just have to live with it. So I read this book, and in this book, there was this beautiful quote. It said, either you go with the flow or you be the flow. Choice is yours. So.
Exactly. I like that.
It's up to you. It's up to you how you take it, right? How you see things. Either the glass is half empty or half full. It's up to you.
Yep.
You know, just just do whatever you feel like is right or wrong.
Evan.
Amen.
Right, will Tracy join? I'm not sure.
Now, she's caught up in another issue we got going on with a customer, so she's wrapped up.
Okay, then Rick is also in a meeting, so I'm not sure if he'll be able to join. However, I'll share my screen so that at least we can go through the presentation. And if Tracy or if Rick joins, great. Otherwise, we'll send a copy to all of them. They can review it, and if they have any questions, then they can let us know.
Oh.
Sounds good to me.
All right, then. Tyler, welcome to our weekly business review. We'll be looking at last week's of information. So the agenda item stays pretty much the same. Executive summary, performance, review, governance, ITBD service offerings, build it 2026, AI by design, US holidays.
schedule then way forward. So executive summary for last week, Harper, as you all know, has started working on the tickets. Last week, his billable utilization was at 32%. He worked on 7 tickets and closed 6 tickets. We will have more discussion on this on the next slide. Okay.
Okay.
But that's the highlight. So I don't have any lowlights. I connected with him at the moment. He's still learning. He's still new. So if there's something which I feel like is worth highlighting, I'll be more than happy to. I checked with him as per the planned activities he mentioned, not at the moment, but I think he's waiting.
to work on certain projects, which I believe you or Tracy will help him out. And the last piece is the help required is the tool access, which Tyler, I know you're super busy. So no rush. Whenever you feel like you can get me added to the reporting part, that'll be great.
That's true.
Otherwise, I am connecting with Harper, so I am getting the information that I need, so I'm good.
Okay, yeah, let me see. I took that as an action item last time too. I just completely let that one slip.
Yeah.
And that's OK. I know we all are busy, so I don't want to put put you under, you know, a certain pressure that you that I needed. I'm like, I have a workout, so I'm good. OK, but anything that you want to add?
Kip.
Yep.
What's that?
Yeah, we.
Yeah, for highlights and stuff like that, like we did actually have him working on some sort of projects. We had him go through and audit all our asset tool. So that's one thing that we also worked with him on. We also had him go through, update some locations for us in our CRM to get him more familiar with that. We've been getting...
Okay.
Yeah.
updated contact lists from our HR departments. So we're just like making sure all the locations and stuff like that are up to date. Thought it was a good way for him to get integrated into the custom or the customer relationship management tool. So he's been working on that stuff too.
Awesome. Yeah, he told me that he was working on a sheet and I think maybe that's what it is, what he's referring to. So hopefully.
Both of them were both of them were on Excel sheets, so yeah, it's probably probably both of them, maybe one of the two, but yeah, the Snipe IT one is our that's our asset tool, so that one's a that was a big one. There were quite a few devices and users that we had to have him go through and audit, and he banged that out pretty quick, so...
Okay.
Okay, cool.
Sure. I'll mention it under planned activities for next week so that we also keep a track of it. Okay. And as for the next piece is the timesheet, which I just wanted to highlight that this is what's happening as for the last week. Overall, if you look at last week was a slow week because we had a holiday.
Yeah, absolutely.
Yeah.
on, you know, Friday, then also he started on Tuesday at midnight. So that's why you see that. I mean, there's nothing that I can actually highlight what's happening, but as I mentioned, it's a work in progress for him. Slowly and gradually, you will see more.
Yep.
you know, tickets that he'll be working on, that's how his billable is going to go up. Then, yeah, that's what I have for this week. Anything that you want to add, Tyler?
Kip.
Uh, nope.
Okay, moving on, performance review governance. This is what we will be focusing on as per our upcoming weekly, bi-weekly, monthly, and then quarterly check-ins. We will be discussing our highlights and lowlights. Anything which we feel like we will propose as per the continual improvements.
and any risks and then providing mitigations towards it. So that's the governance overview. Looking at the ITBD service offering, I believe you are coming to build it, right?
I think we discussed this last week.
Yeah, I am. Yep, I'm gonna try to for sure.
So is the registration done or is it still pending?
No, it's still panic. Yeah, it's not done.
Okay, cool. If you need any information, then we have Rick. He can help you with the registration piece.
Cool. Sounds good.
Okay, then this is our homegrown tool which we discussed last week. That's Team GPS. If you're interested, you can scan the QR code on the screen and we can schedule a demo. US holiday schedule upcoming is September 7th. We have time so we can discuss once we get close to it.
Rest, I haven't heard any other PTUs from Harper. If I do, then I'll share the details with you.
Okay.
Yeah, by design, this time it will be part of our Build It 2026. That is August 5th will be our AI event. Vay forward remains the same. We just want to make sure that Harper continues to focus on escape peers and meeting the benchmark scores.
As per ITBD, we are committed to deliver best product and we are ready to support with any additional needs that may come up this year and also in the coming years.
That's pretty much it from my side, Tyler, for this week. Anything that you want to add from your end? Any questions, concerns, or feedback for us?
Um, no, just uh, I know he said...
Yesterday morning he said he had some sort of issue in the office. Was that, but did he talk to you about that? Was it like network related or?
And interestingly, he did not mention anything about network. Can you just give me more details? What, I mean, like what exactly he was saying?
Yeah, let me talk to him tomorrow morning again. He said that he ran into an issue with like auto task and stuff like that and thought it was network connectivity. So we did, we had him do some like ping tests and stuff like that. So that was basically it. Also, the other thing I have is we might have to provision him a VDI. You guys don't have anything where you allow him to be an admin on his machine, do you? Like if he's running?
Okay.
Ohh.
Kam.
like PowerShell, stuff like that, yeah.
No.
Yeah, the reason we have restricted this access, it's not only with Harper, it's with all the engineers. We have restricted the access for admin privileges. But for obvious reasons, we don't want anything to get installed and then we face the consequences. So it's restricted for everyone, actually.
Yeah.
Yeah, no, that's fair enough. I figured out just to see what, see what some other companies do, like best practices.
VDA, yeah, VDA is the best practice. That's what the majority of our partners are doing.
Cool. All right. That's the direction we were moving in. So that's good to hear. So we'll do that. And then other than that, I don't have anything. Like you said, it was a pretty slow week last week. People take off and we had off for the holiday and everything. So all good for my side.
Oh.
Awesome.
Okay.
Awesome. Anything from Tracy perspective, do share it with me. Tyler, you can send me an e-mail or maybe Tracy can also shoot me an e-mail. I'll be more than happy to answer her queries. Okay, rest, Rick, anything from your end?
Oop.
I'm good for now, Evan.
Rick just sneaked in and he was just listening to our conversation.
Partner.
Yeah.
Yeah, my last call got got extended, well, sorry.
He's A sneaky guy, man. Rick, you being sneaky?
He really is.
Kip.
So, you saw yesterday, Matt Tyler?
Oh, absolutely.
We already discussed this, Rick. You are late. You need to join these meetings on time, then we will discuss FIFA.
Oh man, because I missed it. So Sushant was sitting next to me and it was like 30 minutes left and he was like, it's 20, right? And Tyler, I usually don't watch that much football.
Ohh, but...
Yeah.
till last year, but while it's the World Cup happening and everyone is excited on the floor, so I'm watching this this year now. So I was like that within next 30 minutes, will this Argentina will capture this? Is it possible? And within the last 15 minutes, everything got changed, man.
So, yeah, yeah.
It was crazy. It was crazy. I was on a call and I had it on in the background. And the guy I was on a call with is a big sports fan too. So we were just like going through some policies and stuff that were getting in place for his organization. And like the goals were happening. And I was like, oh my God. I was like, oh, they pulled one back. And then 5 minutes later, I was like, yo, they just tied it.
Yeah.
Kip.
Yeah, it was crazy. Then some of the like calls that got called back and like, yeah, it was it was crazy. A lot of controversy around that one, but hey, it is what it is.
It was Vaid.
Yeah, man, he's saying it's fixed.
Yeah, I know. I love it.
But people people saying it wasn't fixed till it was 20.
Yeah.
What's funny is like, there were some calls that weren't called and stuff like that, but at least like all three goals that they scored were like, like they weren't penalty kicks, like they weren't given like penalties or anything like that. But at the other end, it seemed like Egypt should have had a penalty. But yeah, a lot of controversy going on, but hey, it is what it is, man.
After that, it got fixed.
Yep.
That's sports for you. That's the ups and downs.
Yeah, happens same in cricket as well. But yes, it was, it's always great connecting with you, Tyler.
For sure.
Kip.
Yeah, yeah, you guys as well. I'm happy to do this and looking forward to seeing how Harper grows and how we can grow together.
Yep.
Awesome. Thank you, Tyler. Say hi from our end to Tracy. Tell her that we miss her. Hopefully she can join next week's hurdle. Connect. So just for everyone's information, Tyler, as we move along, we will be changing our service call cadence to biweekly and then monthly.
as per the progress. Okay. So I know connecting every week can be a monotonous thing. So we don't want to, you know, get into that situation. But as we move along, once things are sorted, we will move this to biweekly and then ultimately to monthly. Okay.
Okay.
Cool, that sounds good to me. Absolutely.
Great. So thank you so much for time for this week, Tyler. We'll speak to you next week. Till then, have a great week ahead and fantastic weekend. We'll see you next week. Till then, have a good one. Bye-bye. Take care. Bye.
You as well. Appreciate it. See you guys.
Hey, Ketan.